la sphère ppda qui a explosé en début
d'année s'intensifie chaque jour
l'écrivaine florence porcel qui accuse
l'ancien présentateur du 20 heures de
tf1 de viol au moins deux viols dans les
années 2000
florence porcel et la journaliste qui la
première a accusé ppda de viol à deux
reprises aujourd'hui face à la défense
du journaliste et à la remise en cause
de la faire par certains elle a décidé
d'en dire plus au journal le parisien
elle répond d'abord sur ceux qui
l'accusent d'avoir sorti la faire pour
promouvoir la sortie de son livre déposé
plainte pour viol c'est très violent
même onze ans après les faits si c'est
juste pour la publicité je peux vous
dire que le jeu n'en vaut pas la
chandelle
j'ai tout à perdre elle a ensuite réagi
à la défense de ppda dans les médias qui
réfute les accusations
je m'attendais à l'obscénité de cette
réaction je ne suis pas surprise elle se
dit très ému des nombreux témoignages
qui valide son récit et précise qu'elle
souhaite maintenant que ppda répondre de
ses actes devant la justice
[Musique]
après j'ai ou parler d'une histoire qui
vient de tomber la incroyable ouais je
vous la racontez vous avez voix
incroyable pour l'instant sur cette
affaire gilles verdez alors florence
porcel durci le ton sur le plan
médiatique c'est très intéressant le
parisien quotidien généraliste et l
hebdomadaire avec un lectorat plus
féminin elle voulait reprendre pied là
dessus parce que ppda avait parlé d'un
quotidien et donc là elle veut dire sa
vérité et surtout c'est une manière de
mettre la pression très fortement sur
les enquêteurs la justice je ne
laisserai pas tomber je veux aller un
procès en disant que le viol supposé un
présomption d'innocence que le viol
supposé de 2009 n'est pas prescrit donc
elles vont maintenant un procès terme
encore bernard montiel vous avez des
malheurs lui ce que dit patrick poivre
d'arvor suite à tous cette malheureuse
affaire il dit les écrits de madame
porcel que j'ai conservé pour la plupart
postérieure à ces accusations le
prouveront amplement parce qu'il a gardé
tous les mails elle est spécialisée mais
l'avait envoyé plein après toutes ces
affaires les prix bondissent de mais bon
faut des mecs qui vend non non mais qui
vont le disculper d'après ce qu'elle
raconte sa liste des mails envoyés pas
de mail ou très peu bon bah oui dans ce
cas là dans cette interview si c'est que
ppda lui a vraiment fait miroiter des
choses professionnellement pour obtenir
des choses d'elle lui aurait fait
miroiter des choses
donc ça si c'est le cas c'est vraiment
dégueulasse après on
après aussi faim on réapprend quelques
s'est rendu chez lui à plusieurs
reprises il faut dire que voilà c'est
pas parce que quelqu'un est connu qu'il
faut accepter tout de suite d'aller à
son domicile c'est pas normal d'aller
chez quelqu'un tard le soir juste parce
qu'il est connu
donc je pense qu'il faut dire aux
personnes connues et puissante d'arrêter
de se croire tout permis et pour
certains je dis pas que c'est le cas des
bdr mais de se comporter comme des porcs
puisqu'on parle de balançon port et pour
les autres de ne pas accepter d'aller
chez quelqu'un juste parce qu'il est
connu
je vais vous raconter une histoire qui
va vous intéresser qui est folle et
géraldine à vous intéresser
particulièrement parce que vous êtes fan
c'est l'histoire qui concernent novak
djokovic le numéro un mondial du psg
revient de tomber regardez cette
histoire et l'interview exclusive de
natalia skitch une mannequin serbe a été
publié dans un magazine
la jeune femme révèle avoir été
sollicité pour participer à une
opération marque particulièrement
malveillantes dont la cible était novak
djokovic elle dit un homme que je
connaissais et que je croyait jusque-là
sérieux m'a contacté pour un rendez vous
que je pensais professionnel au fil de
notre conversation j'ai vite compris que
quelque chose n'allait pas je pensais
même à une caméra cachée quand il m'a
expliqué que je devais séduire novak
djokovic il m'a dit que je pourrais je
pouvais obtenir 60 mille euros pour cela
est un voyage où je voulais j'ai rigolé
je pensais qu'il allait me dire qu'il
blaguait mais cet homme était très
sérieux rapidement l'objectif immoral
lui étaient présentées elles devaient
tout faire pour charmer novak djokovic
dans le but d'enregistrer une vidéo de
leurs rapports sexuels à son insu la
sextape aurait ensuite été dévoilée au
monde entier pour faire scandale et
porté atteinte à sa réputation au revoir
à sa carrière
je me suis sentie offensée humilié même
il préparer vraiment un plan
machiavélique jeu de vendée novak dans
un endroit intime et toupie mais en
entendant ça j'ai pris mes affaires et
je suis parti j'espère qu'ils ne
trouveront pas une fille qui acceptent
de faire ça c'est quand même incroyable
il va nous sortir que serviront des
comptes mais les stars internationales
comme novak djokovic n ai marre aussi
qui a eu des histoires comme ça comment
ils font aujourd'hui donc pour pour
aborder une vie sentimentale normalement
ils doivent avoir peur de tout
maintenant avec les réseaux sociaux les
enregistrements les captures d'écran
c'est terrible c'est illogique serré
mais dans une certaine presse anglaise
et d'un tabloïd trash anglais qui
faisait ça il sollicitait y paient des
jeunes femmes pour séduire notamment des
footballeurs professionnels unfp où sont
tombés dans le piège
ben oui
écoutez franchement pas là nous a déjà
fait ça bouge à la casse tête j'ai
failli tomber dans un piège
non c'est pas vrai que c'est vrai bah
oui j'ai bien fait il ya quelques années
j'ai failli tomber dans un piège si vous
n'avez jamais jamais jamais là j'avais
eu une relation avec quelqu'un mais je
serai pas parler plus fort il est là mon
micro effectivement on devait se
retrouver quelque part et je sais pas
j'ai senti j'ai senti le piège est
effectivement il y avait des paparazzi
qui étaient là donc le but et quoi de me
faire prendre en photo avec la personne
mais après des bandes me faire chanter
grâce à dieu j'ai page pas dans le piège
mais c'est vrai que face à une méthode
honnêtement pour les gens connus c'est
assez c'est assez
merci géraldine va devenir très
compliqué parce qu'on peut lire ici que
c'est le contrepoint et le contrechamp
de la sphère personnelle c'est à dire
que d'un côté et les femmes qui sont
souvent prises qui peut leur adresser
liste et de l'autre il ya des rames
qu'on va payer ou des femmes qui vont
être mal intentionnés pour faire tomber
des puissants et prenez pour couper des
têtes
hu voilà donc ça va devenir très très
compliqué j'adore leur entre les hommes
et les femmes
oui il a raison ça est toujours existé
dans les tabloïds anglais mêmes défauts
de certains tabloïds italien en revanche
l'époque avec mitu et balances ton porte
m'a favorisé deux noms de nombreux excès
dans ce genre là willy et puis guillaume
tu as quand même dit il faut faire
attention faut plus inviter les jeunes
filles ou les jeunes doivent plus y
aller
enfin t'as même pas être jeune fille tu
as parlé de femmes moi je suis pas
d'accord avec toi parce qu'avant on est
on va tous devenir parano et je vois
pourquoi un homme aura pas le droit non
une femme le soir et une femme c'est à
l'envié d'y aller on ne pourrait pas
aller voir un homme qui soit connu ou
pas jeudi un chacun est libre de dire il
ya des caméras ya des trucs un peu plus
et j'en passe et ça ils parlent de
chambres d'hôtel voilà deux pages
officielles veille à l'elysée vous
apprennent des choses parce que les gens
qu elles étaient deux
nathalie que tu lis non moi aller chez
une personne juste pourrait dire un
coucou non parce que c'est pas possible
pour moi avec ma personne mais j'ai pas
aller chez cette personne si lé cac
seuls ksila sur l'envoi à l'ag d'hier
elle a pas forcément mais elle a parfois
juin voir contrainte ou parce que là
elle parle d'un prix sema jeunes femmes
ont pris mais ça peut faire une
ouverture îles aland midi les open nommé
ça qu'on avait les gens c'est pour ça en
fait c'est pour ça que l'article de
porcel elle est très très très faim il
est très intéressant parce qu'il est
différent parce qu'ils montrent
justement tout le cheminement
psychologique parce que d'un côté c'est
y aller pas y aller est à emprise pas
être sous emprise
ces pages à lire donc je l'admirais ce
que j'ai dit elle des casiers pas dsk
lits retournés 1 1l mairie dit florence
elle dit elle elle dit qu'elle a été
violée apprendra que la deuxième fois
d'état sont ici elle était consentant à
un acte consenti mais sauf que elle dit
maintenant c'était consenti mais sauf
que maintenant je pense que j'étais
souvent prise à voir mais tcc c'est tout
ce cheminement psychologique
là oui mais c'est voilà c'est donc c'est
très compliqué c'est ça une meilleure de
définir juridiquement le terme dans
prises par son pays mettre tout et
n'importe quoi dedans